spent just over a month since China
started backing away from code with zero
but the country's only reported 16 covet
deaths that's in a country of 1.4
billion people given what we know from
other places after they reopened as well
as China's own experience the low
fatality rate just doesn't Stack Up
[Music]
when it comes to the covert data in
China we can't trust the cases data it's
completely not representative they have
severely narrowed the definition of what
a covert death is China like a lot of
places in the world saw anybody who died
while they were covered positive as a
covert death now only people who die
while covered positive from a
respiratory condition are counted as a
cover death and that's why you've seen a
dramatic drop in the number of deaths
and you've just not seeing any deaths
reported on some days despite what we
know to be a rip-roaring outbreak
Beijing seems to have been hit hardest
we're hearing about crematoriums that
have been overwhelmed hospitals with
bodies piling up
because it's in their interests now that
they've switched to living with covert
they want to see a really big bang fast
outbreak that they can then just move on
from official rhetoric from scientists
to the top leaders is that covered is
very mild you're very unlikely to die
from it that it's something you can work
with
there's no doubt that covert zero the
lockdowns
damaging to China's economy that was a
key pressure point on why they needed to
shift away from it because covert is
coursing through the country people are
sick people are afraid of being sick
people aren't out consuming and you are
going to see disruption on what is you
know the world's Factory floor but what
a lot of economists are betting is that
that first initial wave will pass over a
couple of months and then people like
they have elsewhere in the world will do
things like Revenge spending I do think
we will see that but I think that people
are under playing the fact that covert
doesn't go away it's not going away
anywhere in the world so that's
something China will have to Grapple
with